so diese Karte hier haben wir schon
dutzende Male gesehen hier befindet sich
das James webteleskop im Weltall und
hier das plankteleskop und hier das
hörschelteleskop in all diesen
Darstellungen Kreisen sie um diesen
Punkt hier L2 aber hier wo immer L2
steht ist gar nichts warum sind die
Sonden und Satelliten dann hier und für
die von euch die das Rätsels Lösung
vielleicht schon kennen warum Kreisen
sie um diesen Punkt und schweben nicht
einfach in ihn
als allererstes frohe Weihnachten und
Happy Birthday nicht Jesus sondern James
Web Teleskop am 25 dezember 2021 heute
vor genau einem Jahr ist das James Web
Teleskop gestartet und zur Feier des
Tages verlosen wir die allerletzten
James Web T-Shirts die wir noch im Lager
hatten und zwar unter allen patients
wenn ihr teilnehmen wollt weil ihr kein
Shirt mehr bekommen habt dann müsst ihr
nur bis zum Ende diesen Jahres
unterstütze auf patreon sein und ihr
nehmt automatisch an der Verlosung
Teilen okay wo fahren wir stehen
geblieben ach ja eigentlich bei diesem
mysteriösen L2 bei dem aber nichts ist
außer verdächtig viele Sonden und
Satelliten von einem ganz bestimmten Typ
im grob im Ganzen gibt es nämlich drei
Typen von Sonden und Satelliten die
ersten sollen irgendwohin und werden auf
ihre endlose Reise durchs Weltall
geschickt tschüss und auf nimmer
wiedersehen dazu gehören zum Beispiel
die Voyager Johnen
die zweite Art soll Infos über unsere
Erde liefern und kreist über unseren
Köpfen in der Erdumlaufbahn und dann
gibt es noch eine dritte Sorte bei der
die Geräte ohne störende erdeinflüsse
die großen Fragen des Weltalls
erforschen sollen das heißt Sie dürfen
nicht zu dicht an der Erde dran sein
müssen aber auch irgendwie in Erdnähe
bleiben und zu dieser dritten Art gehört
das James web-teleskop das ist seit
knapp einem Jahr in 1,5 Millionen km
Entfernung von uns positioniert und zwar
an einem sogenannten
Lagrange Punkt da groschpunkte sind Orte
an denen sich die gravitations- und
Zentrifugalkräfte mehrere Massen
ausgleichen bzw wenn wir ganz
physikalisch korrekt sein wollen sich
die effektiven Gravitationskräfte
ausgleichen okay so weit so Waage hier
in unserem Video geht es vor allem um
Konstellationen mit zwei Himmelskörpern
bei denen einer den anderen umkreist z.B
der Mond die Erde die Erde die Sonne
it so ein gespannt hat immer fünf fünf
Punkte wobei zwei davon ganz anders sind
als die anderen drei an Lagrange Punkt 4
und Lagrange Punkt 5 kann ich Sachen
abladen und in 5 Millionen Jahren
wiederkommen und sie sind immer noch da
bei L1 L2 und L3 ist das nicht so sie
sind instabile Punkte das heißt was
dorthin geschickt wird muss ich immer
wieder mit einem kleinen Manöver am
Platz halten das ist auch der Grund
warum das James Rap Teleskop am Lagrange
Punkt 2 leider nur eine begrenzte
Lebenszeit hat irgendwann werden ihm für
die Manöver schlichtweg die Treibstoffe
Hydrazin und die Stickstoff tedoxid
ausgehen bis dahin ist aber noch relativ
viel Zeit denn trotz des spritbedarfs
für die Manöver spart man durch das
Parken an Lagrange Punkten enorme Mengen
Treibstoff aktuell gehen die
Forscherinnen und Forscher der Nase
davon aus dass das James Rap ca 20 Jahre
lang aktiv bleiben kann die Frage warum
an diesem mysteriösen L2 nichts ist ist
also schnell beantwortet Lagrange Punkte
sind keine Objekte sie sind nichts mit
eigener Masse oder Anziehungskraft sie
sind vielmehr ein Punkt im Raum an dem
sich Anziehungskräfte verschiedener
Massen genau die Waage halten sich exakt
ausgleichen aber wenn das genau an
diesem Punkt so gut funktioniert stellt
sich doch jetzt die noch viel
spannendere Frage warum kreist das James
Rap Teleskop dort um diesen Punkt herum
warum parkt es nicht einfach mitten im
Lagrange Punkt und macht den Motor aus
das würde ja unser treibstoffproblem
lösen tatsächlich vollführen alle
Satelliten und Sonden an L1 und L2
solche Kreise sogenannte liberation
point Orbits wie lissaju oder Halo
Orbits Halo Orbit schließen zumindest
von uns ausgesehen irgendwann den Kreis
lissaju Orbits erinnern einen eher an
diese samt Pendel aus dem Massagestudio
willst du in der Zukunft auch bei der
Nase der ESA oder dem DLR arbeiten und
an Missionen wie den James Rap Teleskop
mitwirken oder vielleicht der
allerersten Marslandung dann solltest du
jetzt aufpassen denn ich habe eine super
Möglichkeit für dich
seht ihr schon plus Mint das ist eine
Talentförderung für junge
mintbegeisterte die euch und eure
Fähigkeiten in einem von sieben
Internaten in Deutschland fördern wenn
ihr dort angenommen werdet habt ihr die
Möglichkeit mit vielen Gleichgesinnten
noch tiefer in die Fächer Mathematik
Informatik Biologie Chemie Physik und
Technik einzusteigen an den Internaten
habt ihr einen geregelten Schulalltag
mit Fokus auf euer Spezialgebiet im
MINT-Bereich ihr könnt quasi den ganzen
Tag lang lernen forschen und euch mit
Wissenschaft auseinandersetzen um in
Zukunft die besten Chancen zu haben und
abends habt ihr dann auch noch die
Möglichkeit mit Freunden Sport zu
treiben oder andere AGs zu machen die
Förderung ist für Schülerinnen und
Schüler ab der 9 Klasse und aufwärts die
sich durch besondere Leistungen in einem
MINT-Fach hervorgetan haben und die
Bewerbungsphase für das kommende Jahr
läuft noch bis zum 31 Januar falls Sie
also so richtig Bock auf Mint hat oder
jemanden kennt auf den oder die das
zutrifft dann schickt ihn doch einfach
dieses Video hier oder schaut über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung auf plus
mint.de vorbei und wenn ihr euch mal
ansehen wollt wie es in einem der
Internate so aussieht ich war letztens
in luisenlund unterwegs und habe dort
drei Videos gedreht die verlinke ich
euch auch noch mal unten in der
Videobeschreibung übrigens gibt es bloß
Minden endlich auch in Bayern das
Internat Neubeuern in der Nähe von
München ist das 7 mint-leistungszentrum
in Deutschland ich drücke euch die
Daumen für die Bewerbungsphase okay
zurück zu den liberation point Orbits
für diese Orbits gibt es verschiedene
Gründe je nachdem wo man ist und was die
Mission benötigt oft soll damit eine
Eclipse vermieden werden also eine
Überlappung von Erde und Sonne aus Sicht
der Sonde das hat zum einen mit der
Energiezufuhr zu tun wenn ein Objekt
genau im L2 Punkt ist befindet sich in
einer Linie mit Erde und Sonne und damit
im Erdschatten die Solarpanels von
manchen Missionen bekommen hier aber
nicht genug Sonnenlicht ab daher Kreisen
viele hier in einem Winkel der groß
genug ist um dem Erdschatten zu entgehen
auch für die Temperatur sind
gelegentliche eklipsen blöd wenn das
Objekt immer wieder in den Erdschatten
hinein und wieder herausfliegt verändert
sich ja jedes Mal die Temperatur was
nicht alle Geräte problemlos mitmachen
am L1 ist das Problem genau umgekehrt
hier versuchen die Missionen zu
vermeiden dass die Sonden und Satelliten
aus erdsicht direkt vor der Sonne landen
denn das sorgt häufig für
Kommunikationsprobleme daher berechnen
die Forschenden noch vor dem Start sehr
weit in die Zukunft wie eklipsen
möglichst gänzlich vermieden werden
können diese Berechnungen haben dann
auch Einfluss auf die Wahl des Typs und
sogar auf das Startdatum der Mission
tatsächlich ist aber auch die Wahl des
richtigen Lagrange Punkt super wichtig
für eine Mission denn der bestimmt was
für Untersuchungen möglich sein werden
der Lagrange punkt 1 ist die go2-adresse
für alle die schön braun werden wollen
denn es ist der ideale Punkt für
Sonnenbeobachtungen das europäische
Sonnenobservatorium Soho nutzt ihn zum
Beispiel aber auch das Deep Space
climate Observatory hat hier Geräte
geparkt denn man kann permanent die
Tagseite der Erde beobachten
über Lagrange Punkt zwei haben wir hier
in der Redaktion ehrlich gesagt einen
Running Gag am laufen egal über welchen
neuen Kassen Satelliten oder über welche
Sonde wir gerade berichten die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie am Lagrange
Punkt zwei chillen oder zumindest mal
gechillt haben ist ziemlich hoch
Herschel Plank Gaia ucat das ist eine
richtige Party im Weltall ja so wird den
wenigstens nicht langweilig da oben die
Ariane gut beschreibt ihn sogar als
Zitat ideales Domizil für das James Web
so als würde es sich dort oben ein Haus
bauen naja ziemlich viele Vorteile hat
diese Immobilie ja auf jeden Fall man
kann von dort aus noch gut mit der Erde
kommunizieren ist aber mit
entsprechenden Abstimmung weit genug weg
um ohne störende erdeinflüsse in die
Tiefen des Weltalls schauen zu können
L3 könnte man eine Oase der Ruhe nennen
oder auch den nutzlosen er liegt von uns
aus gesehen genau hinter der Sonne und
ist somit wieder erreichbar noch jemals
sichtbar dafür ranken sich die
weirdisten Geschichten um ihnen von
einer zweiten Erde bis hin zu einer
feindlichen Alien macht die sich dort
verstecken soll solange keiner das
Gegenteil beweisen kann sind der
Fantasie wohl keine Grenzen gesetzt
L4 und L5 sind quasi die unordentliche
Rumpelkammer unserer Erde da sie stabil
sind stabil wurde da sie stabil sind
sammelt sich dort alles mögliche an Müll
und niemand träumt auf die Erde hat dort
z.B ein paar nicht so spannende
Gesteinsbrocken gelagert ganz nutzlos
sind L4 und 115 dann aber doch nicht
auch einige weniger bekannte Sonden und
Satelliten befinden sich hier und auch
die Militärs dieser Welt interessieren
sich übrigens sehr für Lagrange Punkte
verschiedene Länder planen dort
Satelliten zu positionieren die den
Flugraum zwischen Erde und Mond so wie
hinter dem Mond überwachen und
patroullieren sollen Sina hat mit Hilfe
der Lagrange Punkte sogar schon eine
Funkverbindung zu einem Länder und Rover
auf dem Mond Rückseite aufgebaut mit dem
die Kommunikation normalerweise von der
Erde aus nicht möglich wäre
das ist also das Rätsels Lösung das ist
der Grund warum das Web und seine
Freunde in Ihrem idealen Domizil nicht
schweben sondern Kreisen und warum sie
um ganz viel nichts Kreisen und wenn
jetzt alles zum James Web wissen wollt
dass er gerade sein einjähriges feiert
dann empfehle ich euch dieses Video hier
bis dahin bleibt stabil euer brudi
krench